Uh, I think it is funny and ironic to be
the uh, [music] wife guy who doesn't
have a wife.
>> Is wife guy really your ultimate, you
know, peak life or or would you actually
rather be the guy who changed nines and
tens for your whole life?
>> Um, can I defend my uh my honor even if
they're not attacking me along this
line?
>> They've been attacking you the whole
time. Um,
>> excellent. Perfect.
>> Okay. How's how's it going, Connor?
>> It's okay. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. Have you been following
anything that's been popping off today?
>> I have. Um, so
>> any thoughts on that before we get into
the rest of it then?
>> Sure. Um, is what happened? They found
some Discord where two creators were
talking about they were trying to find
Teone, figure out whether or not Teone
had an alt, but because they were using
open-source intelligence tools,
uh, Destiny and Dan were asserting that
this is evidence of gay ops operations
against DGG.
>> Yeah, doxing specifically, but yeah,
basically.
>> Okay. Uh yeah, I
I I would obviously like to see based
off of the allegations that they're
saying the commentary community has been
going after them and specifically
responsible for doxing or swatting. I
obviously would love to see something
more substantive than that.
>> Awesome. Wow. Great to hear. Great to
hear.
>> Yeah.
>> Um Okay. I mean, any other thoughts on
it or is that is that basically all
you've got to say about it?
>> No, no, it was uh it was good to see the
band get back together.
>> Oh, yeah. It
>> was [laughter] to see uh Chud Logic back
in orbit. That was fun.
>> Yeah. I don't think uh that's going to
stay that way to be honest, but
[laughter]
>> I know I'm around.
>> Okay. So, right, we're here to talk
about your divorce, Connor. Mainly, I
think.
>> Um
>> Yes.
>> Which you obviously the other day you
spoke on stream quite extensively about
uh your your divorce and the sort of
fallout from that.
>> Um
what what do you think the reaction
that's got? And I I spoke to you briefly
about it in DMs. I think you said
something about it, but how do you feel
about the reaction? which I know a lot
of people have actually covered that
which uh I'm sure you most of us
probably don't get covered a lot but
I've actually seen a lot of people
covering your divorce story. I saw moral
covering it. I saw this guy Nos covering
it. I saw Chud covering it. Everyone's
been over it.
>> Everyone's been over it. So
>> yeah. I I kind of feel like it's damned
if you do, damned if you don't. Um I
understand I probably overshare compared
to a lot of other creators, but um I've
always been very open about my personal
life. So, if you're going to be open
about the W's, I think you need to be
open about the L's as well. So, I'll try
to be as open as I can be.
>> Yeah. My my sort of I mean, just tell me
where where I was at with it. I did say,
you know, why would you put this on the
internet? Because it is sort of like a
in a mocking way kind of how Chud says
it. Um because it is a bit, you know, a
lot of it is a bit TMI. Uh but broadly,
you know, I don't actually have an issue
with, you know, someone being
quoteunquote vulnerable or open online.
It's more when you know if someone's
going to be vulnerable and open do the
whole like here's some embarrassing
information about me please don't bully
me with it you know that's that's sort
of when I find it a bit a bit
embarrassing but I don't think you're
really doing that so
>> no I'm not saying the please don't bully
with it uh with me afterwards it's more
of like and truth be told this is the
way that I I was thinking about it too
is like uh I I do watch your streams on
occasion I watch Chudlo Logic a decent
amount of the time and I think you said
oh Connor telling people how to live.
The [__] wife guy over here. Um,
[laughter]
and I was thinking to myself, it's like
I was proud of having a family. I am
proud of having children. I am proud of
my life in general. Um, so if I'm like
like I said, if I'm going to be sharing
the W's and also, you know, telling
people what I think is right, then I
have to share the L's, too. Otherwise,
it's just [__] dishonest.
Um,
I I wouldn't say it's necessarily
dishonest, but I understand that, you
know, if you're going to you can't keep
presenting yourself as a wife guy,
obviously if you're you're divorced.
That would be that would be dishonest.
You have at some point you have to say
I'm I'm not really a wife guy anymore,
you know. So,
>> well, I'm still Here's the thing,
though. I'm still uh I'm still
spiritually a wife guy, you know. So, so
ju just because I uh I don't have a wife
doesn't mean that I don't think that you
should have a partner, be loyal, uh you
know, try to put their in, you know, try
to uh have long-term interest with each
other, etc., etc. So, that that's still
>> spiritually a spiritually a wife guy
with no wife. Okay. Okay. I see. I see.
Okay.
>> So, so you felt like um because I I'd
say, you know, any anyone can give life
advice ultimately. It's just, you know,
you should know a little bit about them
to to tell whether you should listen to
it or not. So, I don't really see I
disagree with Chard that you shouldn't
ever give any advice because you said
you should be a wife guy and then your
marriage fell apart or whatever the [__]
because, you know, ultimately if if
you've told your audience that then they
can, you know, take it or leave it
really um based on what what they think
of your life. So, so I don't I don't
really agree with that at all. But, um
yeah, I guess I wanted to get in some of
the more some more of the kind of
specifics because you you sort of site
in the stream you say online politics
this job was a big part of that. Could
you elaborate on that at all?
Yeah. So, uh I'll try to keep it brief.
I
love online politics. I I love the
schizophrenia. I love the battles of
personalities, the current events, the
news, all that kind of stuff. And uh
basically, you know, when this was a
hobby, uh I don't think it was as big a
deal um in my relationship um at all
really uh because it was just a hobby.
it's just a side hustle. Um, but as I've
evolved and I went full-time as a
content creator last year, um, I think
that, you know, that's what I want to
talk about. You know, I want to talk
about clashes of personalities, current
events, news, uh, all that kind of
stuff. And so, since it sucked in a
healthy chunk of my personality, uh, it
wasn't like a positive factor. I
wouldn't even put it in like the top
three reasons why we're not together.
Um, but it it's definitely something
that we talked about for sure.
>> It was sort of like the first one you
you mentioned though when when you were
bringing up reasons you did the first
thing you went for was it's online
politics. It's this job.
>> It I mean it it's not
>> was it sort of like just fresh in your
mind or was it?
>> I mean I I would say it's um it's up
there. It's probably not the main
reason, but it's definitely a reason.
>> Were Were there any specific
disagreements that came up as a result
of that? that as a result of the
content. Is that something you're
willing to get into or
>> um well well somebody asked me that in
chat uh earlier and they were like do do
you think it was because of destiny? Um
no it's it's not because of destiny.
>> I'm sure some people would have loved to
have hear that your marriage fell apart
because you're sweeping for destiny but
I I was a bit skeptical on that. I'll be
real. [laughter]
>> No no no no. Um, I I would say that uh,
funnily enough, um, you know, a as much
as it's quote unquote Destiny, it's
everybody, right? So, it's Destiny, it's
Lauren, it's Kyla, it's, uh, President
Sunday, it's you, it's Chudlo Logic,
it's Demon Mama, it's Vosch. Um because
we're I I'm uh you know it's a space
filled with antisocial autistic
political spurs yelling at each other.
Um
yeah, and so that that's not always
everybody's cup of tea, I suppose.
>> I mean I I just I was looking through
some of your VODs and the day after
Charlie Kirk died, you said you had a
massive argument the day before and I
just wonder if that was at all relevant.
Um, uh, did I say I specifically had a
massive argument?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, so the day after, um,
Charlie Kirk was assassinated, you have
a VOD where you talk about how you just
had a massive argument with your
extended family and your wife, and you
left it at sort of like a consiliatory
point, but it wasn't fully resolved.
>> The So, so I don't think that was like a
reason um, a reason for our fracture,
but but I'll I'll tell you her
perspective and my perspective uh, and
the family's perspective. So her
extended family is pretty conservative
and so they basically believe that
Charlie Kirk was and they [__] him. Uh
yeah. Anyways, um they basically like
bought into the line of like Charlie
Kirk was a saint and he didn't do
nothing and the MAGA movement didn't do
nothing. Uh V Victoria had a little bit
more of a a Luigi Manion take of like
well it's bad that it happened but I
understand why. Um, I was probably uh a
little bit calmer than she was and a
little bit less like uh you know making
excuses I suppose of it. Uh but you know
I I I would say I am I'm also of the
it's bad but you know that's our
political climate right now. So I
actually don't think the wife and I
specifically like really split super
hard on that topic.
>> Oh. So that that was just like that that
was an argument more between you and
your wife versus her extended family
then or her
>> in-laws or your in-laws.
>> Um yeah and then also I have a uh little
brother. I don't think I specifically
talked to him about it but basically on
his Facebook post uh he was echoing the
the the martyr complex that um I
basically
>> killed the mother etc etc sort of thing.
it it would have resulted in a knockout
like knockout dragged out fight. So I
just didn't even broach the topic with
him.
>> Right. Fair enough. Fair enough. Um
there was something I was about to ask
off the back of that but I I should
immedately lost it. Um you were saying
you disagreed with the extended fan
Charlie. Oh yeah. Sorry. Yeah. So was it
sort of like wrapped up in sort like
concerns about your safety or was that
not not a factor that was really coming
up? Because I I can imagine sort of like
if you're involved in online politics,
you're talking about that sort of thing,
they might be like, "Oh, why are you
saying this stuff? Cuz you might get
targeted."
>> I wouldn't put that as um I wouldn't put
that as top three to five, but I would
say that that's obviously something that
we discussed about because, you know,
Steven's been docked, Steven's been
swatted. Uh Kyla's been doxed allegedly.
Allegedly. Allegedly. Okay. Um Kyla's
immigration status has been [__] with.
Um I think Hutch got doxed at some
point. PV doxed all the public
information, all that kind of stuff. So,
I've had like a really cavalier um
attitude about like public information
and people knowing who I am and where I
am and all that kind of stuff. Um I
don't think she uh shared my sense of
being cavalier about that.
>> Right. Okay. And was it So, you
mentioned um obviously having to quit
law enforcement as part of the
relationship at some point. Um, was was
that sort of like did that
>> um
>> I don't necessarily I don't necessarily
want to say bitterness, but maybe like
some sort of bitterness that you felt
over that decision carried over into
this new argument over your career now
or
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Just just owning that 100%. Um, so law
enforcement um I analogize it to being
in love with like a toxic girlfriend.
you can know that you can be in love
with something that's bad for you. And
that's the way that I felt about law
enforcement. I was truly in love with
the job. I thought it was cool. Uh I
wanted to become a detective. I applied
for being a detective as I was leaving.
Uh and there was six months there uh
towards the end where she was saying
like, "Hey, this isn't good for us. This
isn't good for our family. You need to
move on." And I tried to fight her on
it. Um and I ended up leaving because
the family is more important than the
job. Uh but yeah, that that 100%. Um
that's that was something that like I
and I I articulated this to her, so I'm
not saying anything new to you. Um that
she acknowledged that it was a big deal,
but I don't think she understood how
deep that like really cut me that I had
to give up what was one of my dream
jobs. Um and it's not that I wouldn't do
it for my family. I would do it a
million times. Um, but when it comes to
this career as well, um, I'm staying at
home. I'm making good money. I'm
arguably making better money than I was
when I was working for a corporation. It
is unstable. It is a little bit more
crazy. Uh, but I'm infinitely happier.
So, when she was expressing that she
wasn't happy with this job, um, I kind
of did tell her it's like, I don't think
it's the job, you know? I I don't think
that's the problem.
>> Right. Okay. Um,
I don't know if I I feel like that could
that could still I mean, obviously I
don't know your relationship, but just
from what you're saying though, it
sounds like it could be about the job,
but it just seems like you weren't
willing to do that twice. You know, I'm
not I'm not faulting you for that. I
probably would, you know, I wouldn't
quit this for a [__] relationship.
That's for [__] sure. But
>> it does sort of sound you just weren't
willing to do it twice, basically.
>> Yes. and and she uh I agree with you
that she can have uh justified anxieties
and resentments and criticisms of this
job. Obviously, this job has a lot of
positives. It also has a lot of
negatives. Um but I think that at some
point this is my personality
>> and so as a result you either like that
or you don't.
>> Yeah, sure. Sure. Yeah, that makes
sense. Um,
I was going to say, um, some other stuff
sort of came [snorts] up as people were
looking through stuff. There was that
old clip of you and Adam and Sitch where
you're on your way to pick up the the
kids and you're you're like having a
very intense argument with them on the
uh through your phone and then your I
believe your wife is in the background
and and says or your ex-wife now in the
background and says um basically oh you
having this argument well you're picking
kids up from school really or something
like that. So was stuff like that was
that coming up or
>> that that didn't come up that much. Uh
but obviously that's not even the only
time that that happened where familial
>> uh familial responsibility conflicted
with online screaming matches. Mhm.
>> Um, so I I I do think just being honest,
uh, yeah, like prioritizing online
screaming matches, uh, while handling
familial responsibilities was
>> like the time when you were I think you
were arguing with chat about lolly and
you had your your kid on your knee or
something, I think.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I know. Uh, I know that
that's probably but but to me like you
have to understand it from my
perspective. So, so that might from an
exterior perspective, people can
obviously be critical of that, but my my
argumentation is earnest. My desire to
take care of familial responsibilities
is earnest.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so I'm not trying to
uh conflate inappropriate subject matter
with raising young families. Um, but I
also feel like it's unfair uh to get
criticized by a bunch of like childless
people over um like, "Oh, well, you're
involving your family with uh with
schizophrenic internet drama." And it's
like, yeah, because I have to handle
both simultaneously.
So, um, yeah. So, so I
>> I'm not drawing any hard judgment on
that. I just, uh, yeah, I I can imagine
that sort of thing being an issue. I
know once as well you
>> have thrown elbows about that in in the
past and it's probably uh partially
true.
>> Um yeah and then there I think there was
another one where you were you were
saying something about sexual
development or lolly and your your wife
like came open the cracked the door and
shouted something in and a little bit.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. No. [snorts] Well and and that's
the that's the thing too. The um here
here's my thing about that too. So she
met me when I had gotten out of the
Marine Corps. So, I got out in 2010, we
met in 2012. So, we also met in the
restaurant industry, and the restaurant
industry was incredibly vulgar. Um,
there's a lot of sexual innuendo in the
restaurant industry. There's a lot of
vulgarity in the restaurant industry,
all that kind of stuff. And she was a
fairly vulgar person. Um, so that's
where like I feel like I I I said the
stereotype, but I think it's true. Um,
you know, men get married expecting
their wives will never change. Women get
married expecting their men will change.
Um, I just I I I've changed obviously
over the past 13 years, but I'm still a
vulgar
um lewd, abrasive, profane person. And
uh she's not those things as much as she
was when she was, you know, she's not
she's not those things compared to 15
years ago.
>> Gotcha. That that makes that makes
sense. Um
I'm I'm forgetting what else I added. I
should have done notes really, shouldn't
I? I really should have done notes. Um,
oh yeah. Okay. So,
one thing I did see in your stream that
was a bit, you know, I did I did it sent
off massive cope alarm bells to me was
um you talking about how, oh, women act
like chores are slavery and they have to
do all this cooking and cleaning and
then you say, I I'm fine cooking for
myself. I go to Publix and pick up a
sushi platter. That's I I think you said
something like that. It's like seemed a
bit like cope to me like you were still
coping about some argument about the
amount of chores being divided in the
relationship and that maybe you were
underplaying how much effort it is to
cook like four or five people or
whatever and and you're you're comparing
that to the experience of now a single
man just going and picking up food from
himself.
>> It's uh yeah uh I agree with that. The
the thing about it is though um that
might that might be coming from a little
bit of resentment. Um and the resentment
is that uh for the past 5 years so since
March of 2020
uh she did not need to have a job. Uh we
were able to pay bills and so I do think
it's fair to categorize the fact I think
this is descriptively true that a
disproportionate amount of domestic
labor fell on her. Um, I have some
conservative women in my life [laughter]
who have articulated
that uh, you know, they didn't have that
luxury and therefore they had to keep up
with an extreme amount of domestic
responsibility and professional stuff.
Um, so yeah, there's there's probably
some resentment there and uh, it could
be very it could be cope. Uh, I could
agree with that.
>> Okay. Okay. Um, I'm trying to think
where where else do we want to go with
this? Oh, um,
some of the stuff about the the the
dating profile stuff. Um,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. How about how about um
how about you uh since I'm uncen
chopped, how about you uh you coach me
on the the dating apps there.
>> I'm going to be wrong. I'm not not a
very dating app guy. I don't really I'm
not a massive
>> Okay, hold on. Let Let me meme a little
bit since I'm the one getting pressed in
the interview. Um, what? Okay. I You and
I have had a very mixed relationship.
Hostile.
>> Say the least. Say the least. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so I guess my question is if
I'm coming on here in order to talk to a
drama streamer to be most vulnerable
about my life. What is your longest
romantic relationship that you've had?
>> Oh man. I I don't think I've ever
said that on stream. Do I want to share
that piece of personal information?
I mean, I
>> am I willing to am I willing to share
that? Let me think about this.
>> Hold on. Before you do, let me let me
say this as a as a fraternal uh uh
offering. Okay. I'm out here naked in
the wind allowing everybody to uh
criticize my personal life and I'm
asking you just this is the only I mean
I could ask more questions, but I but
I'm asking you something so simple
effectively like
>> Yeah. Yeah. Have you had a romantic
relationship greater than a few months?
>> So, yes. Yes, I have. Um, okay. That's
what I say. I I've had
sort of like a, you know, cumulatively
with one person several years, but it
was on and off, but lasted for year or
two at a time. So, that that's like, you
know, so quite quite a significant
amount of time with one person at some
point.
>> That's what I'll say. That's what I'll
say. So, you know, I' I have had
long-lasting relationships. That's not
I'm not uh coming to this as some actual
incel. Okay. I'm not uh
>> I I could say a compliment, but I'm not
I'm not trying to make the tone weird.
So, yeah. Uh keep going.
>> So, I mean, well, that's you asked me.
You just asked that question. I didn't
know what that question was was for.
Uh well the the question is to point the
the the p the exterior perception
outside of commentary is that commentary
likes to throw elbows about other
people's personal lives while not really
having a personal life of their own of
any like notable worth. And so, while uh
I think it is funny and ironic to be the
uh wife guy who doesn't have a wife, uh
you know, I did make a 15-year run of a
single relationship and I do have two
children with whom I continue to plan to
have a good relationship. Um so, you
know, that's kind of the thing. It's
like ideals,
um ideals are ideals for a reason.
There's something to shoot for, but very
oftent times you're gonna fail.
>> Sure. Sure. I just I think maybe what
people see in that though is it's like
you um
you you are you propose the the wife guy
path as like the the best path, but it's
like it doesn't seem like um for
everyone it is. You know, even for you,
it's sort of like you start considering
like a [__] phase. You know, you say
that you would you would just get a
Ukrainian male order bride if your
family wouldn't wouldn't judge you for
it. You say, you know, if you could just
if you're if you're in the position
where you could just [__] eight eight
and nines, eight nines and tens for the
rest of your life, you would do that.
You would chain [__] eight nines and
tens for the rest of your life. So it
doesn't seem like even even to you
really is wife guy really your ultimate
you know peak life or or would you
actually rather be the guy who chain
[__] eight nines and tens for for your
whole life?
>> Well see see that's interesting because
when I was uh when I was 25 I came to
this realization that uh what I want and
what is pleasurable
doesn't always make me happy. And so
this is something that I've tried to
communicate to Stephen. So just because
I'm a male who would love to be a
billionaire who like you uh stated chain
[__] 8 nines and tens in perpetuity,
that's not a real life and that's not
how the world works. And so you know
just because that's like a fantasy
doesn't mean that that's reality. And so
I think people who try to live that
reality often bump up into very bitter
consequences.
Um, sure that I mean I wouldn't
disagree that a lot of those people
probably do have turbulent uh romantic
relationships, but I don't necessarily
see that as being a worse life
necessarily. It could be that some
people actually, you know, enjoy the,
you know, the meeting someone, the
falling out with them, as long as
they're not doing anything necessarily
wrong to the person or hurting them
deliberately. I don't I don't really see
why that's a a worse or less valid life
to to lead than
>> well uh this is where you're going to be
a liberal or a leftist and I'm going to
be a little bit conservative. I think
that the perpetuation of the human
species is something that I value. I
think having like a genetic legacy is
something that I value. I don't think
that that that lifestyle is conducive
either to having children or raising
welladjusted children. Uh, which is why
I would look down on that lifestyle.
>> So, you'd say it's like a social good
thing that you should, you know,
continue the human human race and make
sure the next generation's good and and
all this [__] right?
>> Yeah. And you should prioritize that
over your desire to chain [__] eight
nines and tens.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, I mean, I don't I
don't totally hate that hate that
perspective, but I think when people are
looking for sort of like um life advice,
most people aren't maximizing their life
to have the the the ultimate maximum uh
uh moral impact and they're simply
trying, you know, get through get
through each day without feeling like
total [__] So, I I think when you're
giving life advice, it almost Yeah, go
for it. Go for it.
>> So, you and I operate in the Twitch and
YouTube political space, right? And we
obviously have these like uh larger
than-l life characters who live their
lives uh in kind of extravagant ways.
And I think a lot of the audience
members are like envious of the way that
those people live their lives. And so I
I would rather say what I say and do
what I do and have the minimal impact
that I have in the Twitch and YouTube
political scene. uh rather than
idealizing what I think is like nihilist
hedenism or even being like you seem to
be permissive of nihilist hedenism
without judgment. You're like well it's
you know whatever makes you happy. Um
that's not my attitude. I I I think a
lot of people who pursue nihilist
hedenism even if they get everything
they want they're miserable [__] And I
think people who live envious lives of
nihilist hedenism that they're never
able to f fulfill, I also think they're
miserable [__] as well oftentimes.
>> So what what uh age did you set the
lowest on Tinder to and on Hinge?
>> 22.
>> 22. 22. Jeez. Not not brave enough for
the 18 then. Not brave enough for
>> Well, I didn't I didn't I didn't want to
pull Steven. [laughter]
I I didn't want to get hit by a
17year-old [laughter] pretending to be
18.
>> Okay. Okay,
>> dude. If I If I get catfished by a
21-year-old pretending to be 22, that's
okay. Or like a 20-year-old pretending
to be 21, that that's okay. If I get
catfished by a uh, you know, 17-year-old
pretending to be 18, that's going to be
a problem.
>> That is going to be That's true. That is
true. Okay, that that makes sense. That
makes sense. Um, so it was but it wasn't
due to any moral thing about, you know,
not dating 18-year-olds. You didn't feel
like that would be that would be wrong
for you to do.
>> No. No. But the Okay. So, so hold on.
There there's two there's two concepts
about that because I do think that I
want to moral frog a little bit.
>> Okay.
>> So, I think that um if there is like an
ideal situation where let's say that
there's like a 19-year-old, they know
what they want, they're physically
mature, they're emot just just quickly
for for how old are you, Connor?
I'm 38.
>> Okay.
>> So, I would literally be double that
person's age basically. Um, so in this
hypothetical scenario, uh, if there was
like this perfect person who was mature,
knew what they wanted, knew that they
wanted something short-term, and then
somebody in their 30s could hook up with
them, and then bounce away with no
negative consequences, um, than, you
know, no harm, no foul, so to speak. But
uh when I was in my mid20s, I did have a
promiscuous phase. And I often found
that the people that I was engaged with
in nihilist hedenism. Um they were
escaping trauma. You know, they they
either had a [__] up childhood or they
were addicted to drugs or they had
[__] up relationships or something
like that. And so I think the chances of
you finding somebody with like trauma
that they're coping with uh through
promiscuous behavior is infinitely more
likely than finding the former scenario
that I described. Um and so therefore I
would still, you know, I don't think it
should be illegal, but I I would look
down on it a little bit.
>> Got you. Got you. You don't feel like
that's almost, you know, there's there's
almost some comparisons I can imagine to
the idea of a Ukrainian male order bride
there where she's coming from exploited
countries.
>> Oh, yeah. Toric power dyn
under under attack.
>> Yeah. So, but you don't have an issue
with doing that yourself though, right?
>> War zone. Sorry. Go ahead.
>> You don't have an issue with doing that
yourself though, right? That that's the
only issue over that is that your family
would judge you.
Well, I mean, ideally, I would be
finding like uh you know, and by the
way, I am I am dating someone now
seriously and they're uh they're my age,
too. Um and I and I'm taking it pretty
seriously. But in that scenario, yeah,
it would be like somebody late 20s,
early 30s, has a bachelor's, smart, you
know, all that kind of stuff. And then
hopefully you could build like a real
relationship out of it. Um, but
obviously that's probably not the that
that's not common in the mail order
bride scenario either.
>> Yeah, I was going to say I don't I don't
think those are the those are the women
who are signing up to be mail order
brides are the ones with with college
degrees and [laughter]
>> I I I agree with you. That's probably
not the norm.
>> Um, okay. So, I I had a something in
chat that joged my memory a moment
there, but I
>> Well, hold on. So, so can I uh I can't
see chat, so I can't even get upset if
people are saying rude things. Um, can I
defend my uh my honor even if they're
not attacking me along this line of
>> They've been attacking you the whole
time. Um,
>> excellent. Perfect.
>> So, go for it.
>> So, yeah. [snorts] Yeah. Yeah. So, so
what I would say is just because I think
there's an ideal doesn't mean that I
don't have all the temptations
of any redblooded male. So just because
I consider stupid [__] ideas doesn't
mean that I don't know their stupid
[__] ideas.
>> Okay, makes sense.
>> That makes sense.
>> Okay, Connor, we're we're going to do a
quick test. Okay, this is a quick like
live Tinder test. Okay,
>> sure.
>> You're going to tell me le left or
right? Okay. You're gonna tell me left
or right.
>> Are you gonna share your screen?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So kind of um would you like
to left left or right?
>> Uh hold on. Hold on. You you have to
remind me because I was only on two
weeks. The no category. The X category.
>> Left. Left is X. Yeah.
>> Left. Okay. Yes. Left.
>> Okay. Okay. [laughter] Left. Left.
>> Sorry. That's the only picture I had.
Someone just really wanted me to do
that. So I I [laughter] felt like I
should probably I should do it.
>> No thank you.
>> Okay. Okay. That that's that's a good
answer. That's a good answer anyway. So,
>> um we're fine with that.
>> I appreciate it. [laughter] No offense.
>> Okay. So, how do you think your life
sort of going to change? What are you
doing different with your life now? Are
you excited to be able to do anything
more? Are you going to change how you're
doing internet content creation? Like,
what's your is your outlook changed to
any of this stuff?
>> Yeah. So, uh sorry, this is going to be
a little bit of an autistic speedrun
just because I'm doing a lot. So, uh,
count counterpoints 40k is my back stop.
Counterpoint sci-fi and Star Wars I'm
working on. I'm trying to get up to
weekly content. It's just difficult to
keep it keep up with it. Um, and those
I'm a third of the way onto
monetization. I expect they'll be
monetized by the end of the year. Um, so
those are going to be like my side
hustle back stops that have nothing to
do with YouTube politics. Um, I'll be
deadly honest with you since I'm already
being vulnerable. Anyways, um, in the
live stream genre, I have a very
generous audience, but I'm hard stuck at
50 to 150 live viewers, and I don't like
being hard stuck. It It's [__]
annoying as [__] So, um, I feel like
something needs to change, and all of my
successful friends have found their
niche.
For instance, Josiah from Pondering
Politics, um, has found his niche. And I
think I might need to move to
pre-recorded content. Um, so I've been
talking about it. I've been thinking
about it. I've been scripting [__] Um,
I'm thinking about doing the
pre-recorded 10 to 15 minute uh, yap two
to three times a day model and seeing if
that more fits my personality. Um, so
yeah, like like I'm still going to be a
digital media creator. I'm still making
enough money in order to pay my bills.
I'm still going to have the same
schedule. Um, but I do know that I'm
kind of stuck where I'm at right now and
I have to break through.
>> Right. You don't you don't think, you
know, I I usually to me, you know, I I
can see some im immediate reasons why,
you know, some of your stuff isn't isn't
isn't popping off. It's mainly, you
know, you're you're sort of secluded
away on this Valor Media channel. um a
lot of your you know your your content
when you're um your big ticket content
which is like your big Destiny dramas,
your big Hassan dramas, your big you
know what whatever you know big All Eyes
on this content dramas you're covering
see seem to often devolve into like this
um autistic fighting with chat where
you're where you're pulling up you know
MS Paint charts and graphs uh [laughter]
that look just insane to any any on
look.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No. Um
>> do do you not think maybe like sort of I
guess to bring it around to more of a
question. Do you not think um maybe
going more, you know, pushing the boat
out a bit more would be would be the way
to go about being more involved, being
more in the mix.
Yeah. Uh well well hold up hold up. So
there there's two things that you
described there. So I want to parse them
apart real quick. So I watch your
content. I watch Chudlogic's content. I
watch Nick Dioro. I watch um some other
commentary people just because I enjoy
the content naturally. But I think that
what you guys are good at that I'm not a
and I don't know if I want to be good at
it. Um is you guys are really good at
not only like following and letting like
the content flow, but you basically like
get in, you like throw a couple of
punches and you get out and then you let
the content flow. So on and so forth. Uh
whereas I seem to enjoy the autistic 5
to 10 minute yaps with chat and fighting
and getting one guide and all that kind
of stuff. Uh which I feel like that
parasocial element is why I make a
disproportionate amount of money
compared to my stream size. Um but I
think it makes for a horrible VOD
viewing uh experience, right?
>> And so I've been uh chopping them up
myself. And if you actually look at the
counterpoints politics channel where I
post my VODs, um by chopping them out
myself and basically limiting the
autistic rants, um I have increased
viewership sub.
>> Yeah, that would make sense. That would
make sense. Yeah.
>> Um they are they are better as VODs, but
that actually requires an additional
level of effort that if I just shut the
[__] up instead of going on five to 10
minute rants, then I could save myself a
lot of work. I just don't know if I'm
interested in doing that. Um, when you
talk about pushing the boat out though,
it sounds like you're almost saying you
need to, are you saying that you need to
collaborate more? Uh,
>> I mean that that's part of it. Yeah, for
sure. Collaborating is part of it, but I
also mean just being more in the
discussions as they're happening. I
mean, like when there's stuff popping
off on Twitter or, you know, you're
quote tweeting, you've got clips going
out of you talking about this thing, you
being being part of the discussion and
having um pointed criticisms for other
people involved that you you can try and
hold them to, if you know what I mean.
Just being throwing the punches.
Throwing the punches.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry, say that again.
>> Throwing the punches like you were
saying really is getting in there and
throwing punches. So, so that's another
thing that I have a problem with. And
it's not uh not trying to be a [__]
about it, but like
I like Chud, right? Uh obviously I like
Steven on a personal level. I like Kylo
on a personal level. I like Wick on a
personal level. I like a lot of these
people on a personal level because
they're Twitch and YouTube political
autists. So I know that a lot of people
do make money, get attention, and all
that kind of stuff by uh in my opinion
like if it was like a normal social
circumstance by behaving poorly. Uh, as
a matter of fact, I think Stephen is a
perfect example of somebody who behaves
poorly in a social circumstance, but
he's able to capitalize on the negative
social attention whenever he behaves
poorly. Uh, weirdly enough, I just don't
know if I'm wired that way, which kind
of sucks. Um, I I I just might not have
that dog in me to um, you know, like
like like so for instance, hold on. You
might enjoy this. Did you watch um have
you watched Rob's Media's coverage of
Xanderhal?
>> Um
no, I don't I don't think so.
>> Okay. Well, I've watched your coverage
of Xanderhal. Okay.
>> Um [laughter] the when when you're like
dogging on him and YOU'RE LIKE, "FUCK
THIS GUY. He's an idiot. Low viewership.
Get raped. I hope you you look like
you."
>> I don't say that. I would never say that
on a live stream. I would never say that
on a live stream. I would only say that
in
>> Okay. Okay. But but um Okay. Allow me to
rephrase in case that's terms of
service. Um, le let's just say that
you're throwing elbows. I feel bad, man.
Like, it's funny, but it's like it's
[__] up. Like, you're punching a guy
when he's down.
>> Well, you don't always have to punch
people when they're down. Like, there
are other ways to punch. You don't have
to punch people when they're down. You
can just, you know, punch when you've
got a legitimate criticism for them when
you when you actually think someone's
doing something wrong. But, I feel like
throwing the punches is is important.
being seen throwing punches is kind of
important to a lot of this live stream
debate stuff.
>> So that actually since we're talking
content strategy, I don't know if that's
the most interesting thing to chat, but
I'll go ahead and go with it. Anyways,
weirdly enough, um Hassan [__] is a
horrible viewing experience if you just
pull up his VOD to react to. Um lot of
dead air, lot of meandering, lot of
geopolitical rants that feel 70%
correct. Uh but hating on like a
specific Hassan [__] clip, he says some
wild [__] It's [__] You even get the
context. You get the five minutes around
the clip. Um picking on Hassan [__] um
is obviously u met metrically good, I
suppose. Um and then Nick Fuentes, too.
Uh, but the problem is since I've been a
heel in the Twitch and YouTube political
scene for so long as like the quote
unquote good Republican, I've attracted
a 70% liberal audience and they are so
repulsed by the um by the dissident
right-wing content that they actually
like they [__] They just endlessly
[__] Like they don't enjoy the
content. So, I'm kind of like uh this is
where I'm stuck. I'll wrap the sentence
up. I promise. Um, this is where I'm
stuck where I feel like in order to do
what I need to do, I have to start
punching the far right and interacting
with the far right. Uh, but my liberal
base upon whom I rely financially, they
[__] hate that content. So, my
options are stagnate
um as the quote unquote good Republican
or grow but piss off my current
audience. And I've been uh dreading
making that move.
>> Right. Okay. Well, I [clears throat]
mean, you know, when I started
questioning the uh all the Ethan Klein
stuff about a year ago, I lost a bunch
of people. So, I mean, I I um sort of my
my perspective on all this stuff, it is
usually just, you know, stick to your
guns and piss people. You need to filter
people basically. Almost like dating.
You know, you should be an abrasive
piece of [__] on the first date so they
know exactly what you're worth watching.
anyone clip highlight channel.
>> No, not really.
>> Right. So, so for instance,
>> you're you're kind of like going like,
"Hey, from a content strategy
perspective, bro, this is what I
recommend." But could you have swept for
Ethan Klein even if you wanted to?
>> No, I I I couldn't. But I'm just saying
I'm not even saying necessarily the the
greatest way to make money, but I feel
like making, you know, I don't I don't
want to totally denigrate you here, but
you are sort of in a position where
you're sort of, you know, Destiny's
Republican lap dog. That's sort of like
the the the perception you're going to
have from a lot of a lot of audience.
And having a more distinct identity of
your own, I think, would make you appeal
to because you I feel you've you
probably reached a saturation point with
exposure to Destiny's audience. You've
been on so many times. you you that's
where that's where I first saw you was
in Hippie Dippy Panels back in the day.
Um so I don't I don't see that you know
the next step I feel like would be
having a more distinct identity of your
own and and being
>> you know actually actually push like I
say pushing the boat out and risking
pissing off a bunch of people to take
that next step.
>> Well this is going to be this is going
to be boomer but weirdly enough if it
works then I'll be hopefully reporting
good news to you in about 6 months to a
year. Okay. Uh so the uh Rhino the the
the brand is Rhino uh Republican who is
honest has integrity nuance and
objectives and then hitting the 10 to 15
minute uh one a day. Obviously I'm going
to start with one a day but if um if it
works in the algorithm then I'm going to
try to bump it up to two to three a day
or whatever. And then you know Josiah
and the Midas Touch Bros and the Luke
Beasley's and the you know Adam Mocklers
of the world. Uh, effectively what it
looks like they do is they just spam
three current events a day in 10 to 15
minute segments with like the party
line. Um, so 33% of Republicans are
currently pulling pretty negatively on
Trump. Um, and so I'm hoping that with
the fracture of the Republican party, my
kind of Republican will become they're
never going to be super popular. Uh, but
they'll become more popular again. And
so there's going to be a civil war on
the right that I need to capitalize on.
So, so that's kind of like you're saying
I need to break out of the mold. I'm
hard stuck. I'm saturated with DD uh
DGG. I'm stagnant. Um yeah, I I agree
with you. I I am I am stuck and I have
to do something different unless I want
to stagnate and stagnation in this
industry is obviously ultimately death.
>> Yeah, that that makes sense. That makes
sense. I I don't know that, you know, I
don't I feel like um
being being like the Uncle Tom
Republican is, you know, I don't know
how much mileage there is in in that
specifically. Um I don't know if there's
like
>> Well, you know, the other option I could
always do this. I could go why I left
the right. Turns out I'm a Democrat now.
And then I could just [__] start
sucking Tim Miller's [__] on the
internet. And then that'll probably be
very lucrative. But the same way that
you uh you're built a certain way so you
can only do what you do, I look at that
path and I don't see myself doing it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. No. No. And I'm sorry. Like I'm
throwing a little bit of [__] towards
the [__] the bull work people or
whatever, but yeah, they went from
>> we are the never Trump Republicans.
We're the moderate conservatives. We
still believe in Republican ideals to we
are functionally Democrats.
So now you have to listen to us. And
that's,
you know, I I understand the resentment.
I understand the resentment from Kyle
Kolinsky. I understand the resentment
from Hassan [__] because it's like,
[__] you were a [__] Republican two
years ago, you know.
>> Sure. Yeah, that that makes sense. I
guess just the the way I the way I look
at all this stuff is um
you know if you really want to change
the way people are people are thinking
online you have to um you know sort of
sort of win the influence you have to
kind of take out some of the other
people who are telling them what to
think if you know
>> Yeah. But I but I did it one day and I
felt so cringe. You remember when uh
Hassan [__] tweeted out the shotgun
meme for uh Tom Cotton?
>> Oh yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so Hassan Piger said, what is
it like th those and I've gotten nuked
on Twitter twice now. Last time was
calling Megan Kelly a [__] pedophile
apologist. So,
um, so Hassan Piger tweeted out, it's
like those who make peaceful revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable. And I was like, I could be
spicy on this. And I quote tweeted him
with the [__] uh Shinszo Abbe shotgun
thing.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And then and then I was like, this isn't
me. [laughter] like it's it's funny, but
it it's not me. So, I deleted it.
>> I I guess. Yeah. I I just You have to do
it as you. But yeah, I mean that's
that's
>> um you're saying that's not the sort of
thing you're you're good at. So,
>> um
>> I I don't know how you are in your
family. Um I'm a middle child, so I'm
pretty used to uh you know, they talk
about like middle child syndrome. It's
like you want the attention, but you
don't want to be a [__] about it. You
don't want to like [__] cry about it
or whatever. Uh, unfortunately I I think
I do have middle child syndrome where I
do want the attention. I do want the
money. I do want the clout, but I also
don't want to be a [__] [__] about
it. And sometimes when I see people
acting out in order to get negative
attention, um, I see children throwing
tantrums and it's not possible for me to
unsee.
>> Okay, got you. Makes sense. Makes sense.
>> Okay. Any examples you can think of that
sort of thing?
>> Yeah. So, uh, Destiny [laughter] Uh-huh.
No. Like, so, so for instance, like the
um I'll be specific though, that way if
he watches the clip, he doesn't get
super pissed off. But like the um the
drowned teenage girls [__] God killed
them because they uh didn't or they were
using VPN in order to jerk off and they
were like [__] 10 to 13year-old
drowned girls in Texas. I was like, this
is very clearly a scream for negative
attention. And uh I I did not like that.
Yeah, that that makes sense. I can
imagine why you probably would take
issue with that comment. I can imagine
why a lot of people would take issue
with that comment to be honest.
>> Right. Right. Right. So So So am I am I
jealous of 500 to,500 viewer live
streamers who have established careers,
who are able to make six figures off of
one channel. Absolutely. Am I willing to
talk about adolescent girls jerking off
and being murdered by God one day? No, I
don't think I don't think that's
necessary to get there. I'm going to be
totally honest, Connor. I don't think
that path is
>> ne saying there's limits out here.
There's limits that I don't want to
cross.
>> Yeah, I understand. I understand. I'm
just going to uh chat. If you have any
questions, start putting them in now
because I'm I'm going to just try and
jog my memory with some. I'm not going
to ask anything insane. So, don't even
bother with anything totally [__]
[__] anything about him getting
cucked or stupid [__] like that. Don't
even bother. Right.
>> So, I'll ask real questions.
Um,
but yeah, I mean, anything else you
wanted to talk about while you wait for
questions to come in? Anything on your
mind? Anything you wanted to bring up
with me? We've had we've last time we
spoke, we sort of accused each other of
normalizing pedophilia and then left it
at that. So, uh,
>> yeah, yeah, yeah. Um, yeah. So, I I
heard I heard you speaking with Destiny
earlier today. I'm happy you got the
opportunity to do so. You were being
quite uh, you know, hyperbolic in that.
how in the time that we spoke before
that you were basically saying like he's
a sex predator who deserves to be on a
list and blahy blahy blahy blah and then
all that [__] So I guess my question is
how okay talking about should versus is
and will um how do you feel about his
current legal
predicament?
>> I honestly I I don't understand it well
enough to make a judgment about the
success of the case. Obviously, I think
he should be lose it. Um, my un my loose
understanding is it basically um relies
on the strength of the latest witness
statement they've got or something as to
whether it survives the next motion or
whatever. I I don't I don't know that
much. I haven't followed it super super
closely in the last like six to 12
months. So, I followed it a lot at the
beginning and not a lot past that.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, I'll try not to be a
[__] about it, but obviously like when
the first thing the first bombshells
drop and you know what is it? It's like
January 20th of 2025,
something like that.
>> Yeah. January 25. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, so basically those first
bombshells drop and it's like he's a
[__] pedophile and we need to crucify
him and he should
>> I don't I don't think I've ever
seriously called him a pedophile. I
don't think I've I've ever done that.
>> He's going to jail.
>> I I never said he was going to jail.
I've never said that. I've never made
statements about the outcome. That's not
the case.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, well, there there were
some hyperbolic characters around that
time who were making correlated
statements where with your in Okay. You
might have never said those things. Uh
but they were saying those things
correlated with your enthusiasm for
Destiny catching a black eye. Um so I
guess I guess
>> metaphorical to be clear. Metaphorical.
>> Okay. Um, so, so that's kind of the
thing though. But when I get told, you
know, uh, he's a bad guy, he's going to
jail, he's going to get sued into the
ground, etc., etc. And then, so for
instance, like with the Sherry case, I
think I asked Jtock a couple of times
ago when I talked to him. I was like,
"Hey, have you heard any updates on the
Sherry case?" And of course, I'm being a
smug [__] about it, but the truth is
that like if there was a criminal case
going forward, I feel like we would have
seen that by now. So
>> yeah, I honestly don't I don't know
about the process or what's going on or
so I've got an idea.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You you know your um you
know that uh may maybe even you did it
or but but I I'm sure a quefer did it at
some point. You know where they they
post the the video where it's like they
got your mans. They got your mans the
sex offender you know like all that kind
of [__] Like
>> it just doesn't feel like you guys are
going to get your mans. So you know I
>> Well yeah I don't think he's going to
jail if that's what you mean. I don't
think he's going to jail or something.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'll
>> I mean, the reality is he he, you know,
he did commit the wrongdoing in terms of
sharing Pixie's video in terms of
seemingly obviously we can't prove there
was no consent. We can't prove the
negative. With these Grinder recordings
and the Cherry stuff, it does seem the
case. Um,
you know, as far as getting your mans is
to me it's proving it. You know, that's
that's when you're got is when it's it's
proven. And the pixie stuff is proven
and the other stuff is basically as good
as there. To be honest, it's not really
And by the way, when that when uh when
or if they reach a settlement or if it
gets dismissed, I'm not going to [__]
you're not going to see me on Twitter
like, "Oh, he's totally exonerated."
Like, no. Obviously, he did something
[__] up. Um
>> the other thing is I was never
delusional enough to think that this
would sink his career either. That's the
other thing. Um, obviously, you know, no
no one online,
>> the the only way you get taken out
online is if you do it yourself.
Basically, you you you stop streaming or
you embarrass yourself past what you can
ever recover from. No one else can just
prove you've done wrongdoing and take
your audience from you. That's just not
how anything's ever worked, really.
>> Sure. That's part of the reason why I
agreed to an interview about my divorce.
>> Yeah, fair enough. Fair enough.
>> It's like It's like what are you going
to do? You're going to make fun of me
for my personal life? Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Like it's not it's not that big of a
deal, guys. I'll survive. So,
>> okay. So, I'm seeing some questions. So,
uh do you play Marathon?
>> I don't play Marathon, but I do think
that the company Bungie, despite me
disliking
Destiny 2's narrative, I think they're
really good at gunplay mechanics.
>> Very true. That's very true. And I also
hate Destiny's law, so that's uh Yeah,
totally agree on that. Um,
someone asking I think you answered at
the start. Did Shimu in the Kandra
docks? I think you answered at the
start. Really didn't see
>> I could answer it again real quick. Um,
the what they're trying to substantiate
and I think Queenman will agree with
this. What they're trying to
substantiate is they're trying to
substantiate that Jtock, Queenman, and
commentary people who are critical of
Destiny and Dan are in a Kiwi Farms
incest snark piran like a piranha pool
that is doxing, harassing, swatting
people. And I don't think that's borne
out based off of the evidence that's
been provided so far.
>> Yeah. And you and you wouldn't say that
what you saw from the Carol Shimu was
doxing then?
>> No. Um, and I do think that's an
important distinction within the
conversation is that you guys are saying
like, "Okay, well, they're they're using
PII tools, but if um, who is the guy who
was actually on stream?"
>> Shimu Shimu
>> Shimu. So, if Shimu is being serious
with um saying like, "Yeah, we were
using uh personal identifying
information tools in order to try to
find this guy, but it was properly
motivated by trying to expose techone on
an alt harassing his ex."
>> Yeah, just to be clear, I it wasn't um
you know, it wasn't just a you know,
small uh inaccuracies that I just want
to make sure we're 100% on because
everyone's mad about this right now. Um,
it wasn't Teone specifically
necessarily. It was the account seemed
to be linked to Tee or his friends. And
obviously Teone has in the past
coordinated with people seemingly to
breach his protective order. So when
there's a suspicious account that seems
to be doing that same thing. People were
like, "Oh, okay. What's this? We should
look into this." And it was never
intended to be published. It was to be
passed to Pink Chio for the for for her
legal case. Um, not
>> Yeah. It's while while I can agree with
some people saying like, "Oh, well, you
shouldn't touch the poo. You shouldn't
get involved." It's hard to impugn that
motive.
>> Yeah. I I don't you know, the don't
touch a poo thing. That's a very KF
mindset to be honest. Like Shimu
>> is not like a mass massive KF guy as far
as I understand. I think he's he's like
a kind of right loosely right-wing guy,
but he um just does, you know,
documentaries on insect creators and
stuff like that and he does all the
research himself as well. That's the
thing. He doesn't actually reuse kiwi
farms for his stuff because like the
techone stuff he had to file a bunch of
foyers and all this stuff. I believe
he's spoken to a lot of the people
involved. Got on these sealed court
documents. Some people have gone and
look at them. All this sort of stuff got
gone through all this. So he's he's
really dog. So it was quite a you know
annoyed me personally seeing his
credibility get dragged through the mud
when he's done like a lot of good work
going after just
>> I'm still waiting. I'm still waiting for
the Discord that's like Jaystalking
Queen in a text chat uh chat being like,
"Hey, did you get Stephanie's or wait,
did you get Steven's girlfriend's new
address?" You know, that that's what I'm
looking for. And uh I haven't gotten
that. So,
>> yeah. Cool. Cool. Um right. So, Oh. Oh,
okay. I guess um you said you
>> you can ask me questions. They're rude.
>> You got back with your girlfriend when
you were 15. That's your That's your new
relationship.
>> That's your relationship. Um,
>> you know, has there been has there been
a lot of they super different? Why Why
were you You know, I feel like if I look
back, I think of someone that I knew
when I was 15 and I didn't really know
them past that. I I expect them to be
like totally different. I wouldn't even
know know where to start.
>> We're start Yeah, it's a brand new
relationship. The So, so yeah, sorry
that this might be too wholesome for you
guys. So, when I was 15, I went to uh
like a hip-hop club for teenagers with
this girl a couple of times. I bought
her earrings for Christmas and then we
broke up. That that was it. That's the
totality of the relationship. So, we
actually like did not know each other
that well. Um she could have been
anybody. She could have been like a
total [__] schizophrenic. But um I
saw her at the grocery store a couple of
times over the past several years and
you know I thought she was cute even
though I was married and so I didn't
think anything of it. Um but then when I
found out that I really did not like
dating apps, I remembered that I saw her
at the grocery store and I asked her out
and she's like a fundamentally good
human being. And so I I'm finding it
difficult, you know, like I said, I'm
I'm still a wife guy. Uh, I'm finding it
difficult to find reasons why this
relationship wouldn't work because she's
a fundamentally good human being. But
obviously, I'm only a few weeks out from
my divorce, so I shouldn't be like
making grand sweeping gestures. The only
thing that you need to know is I'm well,
you don't need to know any of this [__]
But, uh, I found a girl. She's very
nice. She's my age. I'm not going to
have a Destiny style uh, sex capade. And
she's very cool and she's a good person.
>> Okay. I I just I I think that's like,
you know, I think a lot of people just
think that's like crazy that you like
hit up some some girl you knew when you
were 15. You married? You still married?
Are you single?
>> I know. [laughter]
>> I think that comes off a little bit
insane.
>> No, it was insane. It was it it was
insane because, you know, I saw her at
the grocery store a few times and she
still had her ex's last name on her
Facebook profile, but she didn't have
any recent pictures with her ex for like
a long time. Um, so when I DM' her at
first, she thought that I was trying to
like cheat on my [laughter] wife.
>> Yeah. Um, so I was like, "No, I recently
got split. You know, can I can I take
you for uh, you know, some coffee or
some tea or a beer or something?" And
she was single, so she said yes.
>> Got you. Got you. Well, I mean I mean
glad glad I'm not denying it craziness.
It's truly a crazy thing to do. I agree.
>> It just worked.
You ask Connor whether or not this is a
cynical ploy to have a carer on call for
his autism.
>> It is.
>> Okay. [laughter]
Okay. I'm joking. Like I don't have
diagnosible autism, but all of the all
of her skills that she uses in work um
are deeply admirable skills that are
probably great for any relationship. Um,
>> so did you does she know about about the
whole internet drama stuff? Did she does
she have you told her about all this
stuff yet or?
>> Yes. So, actually, uh, I texted her
yesterday because I was feeling guilty
cuz, uh, everybody was covering the
divorce [__] and I was like, "God damn
it." Like, I really do not want people
to be like clipping my [__] up stream
moments and DMing them to my girlfriend
and then her having like no reference
for how schizophrenic my world was. So,
I was like, "Hey, can we talk about how
schizophrenic my world was?" And we or
my world is. And uh we had a
conversation and so far she says she's
okay with it. We'll see if that stands
the test of time.
>> Okay. Oh, sorry. I'm just getting like
breaking news coming. Apparently,
>> you got Mimi [__] up questions. I was
expecting more [__] up [__] Go for
it.
>> Ethan Klein is currently posting about
that [__] Discord server on his
Instagram stories. So that's that's uh
that's how far [snorts] this is
>> this is traveling right now which is
just like it's
>> I'm sure he is.
>> I guess I'll get some of your thoughts.
What's your uh so the reason why
obviously server is called the snark
left. That's what he's posted on his on
his Instagram story. Obviously, it's um
it's a deliberate owning of this term
snark that Ethan has used to describe
all of his critics, anyone going after
him, and claim that snark is like this
this evil harassment that needs to be
stopped when it's it's a it's really a
humorous word to use for that. It's like
kind of silly to be crying that snark is
ruining your life. Um, so
>> how do you feel as a Jew?
>> How do I feel as a Jew about about Ethan
Clyde?
>> Yeah.
>> Well, how how do you feel? Terrible
representation. I get it. You're like an
anti-ionist Jew, but how do you feel
about the fact that like Dan Saltman and
Ethan Klein are being like super ligious
and using backdoor?
>> Yes. It makes us look [__] terrible.
It makes Jews look [__] terrible.
Jews look [__] atrocious. Yes,
they're doing the stereotype conspiracy
anti-semitic Jew thing every day. That's
just what they That's who they are. They
are a Jewish stereotype.
>> Um, okay.
>> Obviously Nick Andros tweeted at Dan the
other day. I swear I'm not anti-Semitic.
I just assumed all Jews were like Diddy
Dan. Um
>> if if I can share um Kilo I did review
Kilotonic's uh video on stream. I did
feel like the very last chapter was
sweepy for Hassan [__] but I found
myself uh having difficulty criticizing
the earlier chapters on all of the
creators because the argument wasn't
Hassan good. The argument was look at
the bad behavior of these creators. And
so I realized that like I I can't sweep
for that [__] So I just didn't. So uh
Kilo made a shout out to Kilo. He did
make a strong video.
>> So well I guess let's get some of your
broader thoughts on that. So the sort of
snark narrative thing that the whole
thing is laid out in sort of the first
hour and a half of of that video with
with Ethan. Um what's your take on that?
Did any of that like did you have a
different impression of that drama
before you watched that video? Did that
change your mind on anything? Yes. Cuz I
know a lot of people sort of the way
they sit. This is basically the
narrative that I think most people sort
of have in their head about this drama
is um
>> Ethan was upset about October 7th and
just because he expressed he was upset
about October 7th, Han's chat started
going crazy because they hate him for
being for being Jewish and Hassan
wouldn't do anything about it. And then
the moment Ethan is crying about Hassan
starts attacking him and makes it all
worse and everyone's going after Ethan
and Denims is responsible for the CPS
and bad bad panada is is evil and no one
should ever associate with him and we'd
never do anything like that. You know
that that's sort of the narrative that
that gets spun. So was that sort of your
view? I obviously that's a bit of a
straw man. I'm sure you wouldn't take
that 100%.
>> No, no, no, no. That no that that
relatively speaking that is the uh the
tepid zionist view is look at Ethan
Klein. Oh boohoo, he's getting attacked.
Which, you know, like I still feel like
he can feel like he's being vilified on
the internet. Um, and I think that's
probably true and there probably are
some anti-semitic people in there, but
at the same time, um, you know, I hate
to say this, but like if he did shut the
[__] up about the issue and kind of
moved on with his content, then it
probably wouldn't be anywhere near as
bad. Yeah. But instead he was like, "No,
I'm going to monomaniacally focus on
Hassan, his orbit, and Idubbbz and Ana
Joma, and I'm just going to milk the
[__] out of them for the next two
years." And I thought what Kilo did that
was really good is he chronologized
the uh he chronologized the escalations
of the conflict where effectively Ethan
was you know obviously CPS is like the
main talking point and the skulls but
>> it comes in relatively late in the in
the timeline really. It's like
>> well and that's what's interesting is so
like he started the crit the very
aggressive criticism of Hassan in his
orbit prior to the harassment that he
uses as justification for his very
aggressive criticism of
>> obviously the trap for the content was
laid before the CPS call. It was all
everything was in motion uh to do all
this stuff anyway before any of that
happened.
>> Right. your people.
>> Your your people setting up, you know,
little
>> little back doors propagandistic mind
games, you know. It was good.
>> It was funny.
>> Shout out to my Jews. I do love my Jews.
I'll defend you next stream. I just
think Ethan Klein's being funny.
>> And I I did hear you say, actually, I
did hear you say that you felt like, you
know, Kilo kind of got Dioro's number,
you know, with with uh with that Dioro
segment. Or you said that
>> I can't see I like Dioro's I like
Dioro's content. Uh, but I can't unsee
what's been shown. And and and what's
been shown is effectively like a willful
ignorance. And I don't even think
ignorance is the right term, but I think
you know what I'm saying.
>> Yeah.
>> There's a he's avoided the evidence
deliberately. Yeah.
>> Yes. There's a willful ignorance of
Ethan Klein's uh negative behavior, and
then there's also a willful ignorance of
Turkey Tom's age play allegations. Um,
and he got mad at Chud for saying that
he was sweeping and then he swept. And
it's like, bro, like you can't you can't
get mad at somebody for saying that
you're going to sweep and then sweep.
That's not how that works.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I think he's just using his audience
size knowing that it'll be difficult for
any of his critics to penetrate his
audience. I think he's relying on that
to never address [__]
>> Uh, yeah, I would. I mean, obviously I
agree. Obviously, I agree. But um yeah,
I'm glad I'm glad I'm glad you do. Um
I'm wondering this does the successful
streaming VOD content of watching
something for 5 minutes, pausing every 5
minutes, saying why it's stupid for 30
seconds, and then shutting up and then
doing that ad nauseium for tons of
money. And God bless him in that regard.
But I think that um you know those clips
obviously those clips are a few years
old where he's like the worst thing you
can do the worst thing you can do is dox
and harass people. The worst thing you
can do is go after people's sponsors.
It's like okay if you don't feel that
way anymore explain how.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I agree. Yeah. So Doobie
sent $20 to ask my wife wants me to get
a cheesy tattoo. I don't want to. Should
I leave her and run through damaged
women on Tinder? Appreciate your advice.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh, chibi
>> cheesy tattoo. Cheesy tattoo.
>> Oh, I think it depends on the tattoo. I
think you got to do it.
>> Okay. You You have to get like the
tattoo of your wife's face like Ethan
did. You have to get the portrait. The
portrait of
>> Eli. It depends on the tattoo.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Depends on the tattoo.
>> Uh, hold on. Hold on. Let me let me let
me take treat that as if it was serious
even though I know that it's not
serious. Um, Dubbie should be
financially well off enough that he
takes such good care of his wife that if
his wife wants him to do something
stupid, he should be able to tell her no
and put his foot down. Okay, so gotcha.
That makes sense. That makes sense. So,
Baba in chat here is asking, "When was
the last time you cried?"
>> Um,
February.
>> February.
Okay. I see I see him related to the
divorce.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. There there were some um there
there were some tearful moments, but you
know, we
>> I don't think anyone seriously like
begrudging you cry. They might make fun
of you, but I don't think anyone really,
you know, if they really they probably
cry if they got [__] divorced, too.
Let's be serious.
>> Yeah, that's life, bro. Sometimes life
is going to suck. What are you going to
do?
>> Um okay. Any other questions from chat?
Anything else we want to we want to talk
about or are we sort of uh wrapping up
here? Oh, press him on the cool dad
thing. Yeah, you you wanting to present
yourself as the the cool dad. Be the
cool dad.
>> Turn on the sub and dono notif you
emaciated nerd.
>> Okay, they're telling me this Tim Hy
interview.
>> Also, don't let Bobka bully this man
into crying on stream like she's doing.
>> Is there a different way that that
criticism can be articulated so I can
contend with?
>> So, so yeah. So I think what people are
getting at is it's often seen presented
as viewed as quite almost like an
immature thing to do to try and be the
more popular parent with your with your
kids in the in the co-parenting
um situation. I I think most people see
that as like a unhealthy
>> thing to go about.
>> No, it could be. It could be. And I'm
trying to dial it in, by the way. So, um
I know cuz there there's that
stereotype, right? Like you just like
let your kids do whatever the [__] they
want. That way, um they think you're
cool or whatever. I I understand that's
a stereotype. Um but like, you know,
they eat vegetables. They [__] brush
their teeth every single night. We read
books. Um so, like like the big things
are still happening, but I am, you know,
you got my [__] number if you think
that I'm trying to be the cool dad. Um,
but I'm trying to be the cool dad
because I I think that like boys do need
a little bit of anarchy and so the
household is anarchctic. Like they they
come in like Tasmanian devils, they [__]
up my common area, they spread their
toys everywhere, they play in the dirt,
they run around, you know, all that kind
of [__] Um, but I remember my childhood
and despite my parents being pretty
strict, uh, we were allowed to do stuff
like that as well because we were boys.
So, I will take it if somebody like
hears that and they cringe a little bit
because they're worried like you're
trying too hard to win your kids love
and you will not be disciplined enough
to raise good kids. Uh, yeah, I I'll
meditate on that and try to balance it
out.
>> Okay. Doobie for $20 follows up with, "I
refused to get a prenup because it felt
icky. Am I cursed?"
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Didn't you?
>> Simple answer.
didn't he say um he he has this quote
that he says sometimes it's like uh I am
burdened with glorious purpose or
whatever and uh we've only talked about
it a little bit but I think his glorious
purpose was working really hard for 20
years so he could retire at a young age
with a substantial amount of money um
yeah if you were burdened with glorious
purpose and your wife wants you to get a
dumb [__] tattoo and you don't have a
prenup and she's gonna throw a [__]
hissy fit you have to you have to
balance balance out, you know, putting
your foot down in a reasonable way and
the happiness of your wife. And clearly,
I don't know the balance between those
two things, so you probably shouldn't
ask me. [laughter]
So, good luck, [__]
>> Okay. Okay. Um,
how do you feel, I suppose, how do you
feel about the new lawsuit threats from
Ethan? How'd you feel about the IDOB
stuff?
>> Oh, yeah. What the [__] So, sorry. This
is um this is part of the [__] where I
can't unsee it. So Destiny
>> said that Ethan molested his kids. Yeah.
>> said Yeah. said Destiny said that Ethan
molested his kids and then Idubbbz
brought it up like or Idubbbz at least
this is the way that it was
characterized in the commentary content
that I was watching. Idubbbz brought it
up like, "Oh haha, isn't Destiny so
crazy?" And now he's suing Idubbbz.
>> Yeah. Basically, it was like he brought
it up to say like um the point Idubbbz
was making is that Ethan's too much of a
[__] to go after Destiny, so he won't
he won't like respond to or address that
chat message in the same way he would do
it with everyone else. So I Idubbbz sort
of brought it up on screen because Ethan
was reacting to a lot of his content
that time. Idubbbz scrolled down the the
Snark subreddit, pulled it up, said,
"Oh, I think this is very interesting.
This is very interesting allegation. I
think someone should address." And then
and then he puts it on his screen as
like a watermark for the rest of the
stream. So that if Ethan tries to look
at his stream, it will be on Ethan's
screen, too, is basically the idea.
>> Okay. So So hold up. The My
[__] issue with that is straight up
like I know you're you're like an
anti-religious fellow, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. So if you look at the Sorry, I'll
try to be as brief as I can. If you look
at the Old Testament, the Jew book,
right, the Torah, um they basically have
this uh we talked about barbarian
retributive violence and eye for an eye.
You and I have talked about that in the
past.
>> Yep.
>> Um and that's just like the law of the
land. Eye for an eye is better than
barbarian retributive violence, but
there's still plenty of barbarian
retributive violence in the the Torah. I
think that turning the other cheek, I
was raised Christian. Um, while I'm not
a Christian literalist, I think it's a
better way to live both for society and
for individuals. And the fact that Ethan
Klein cannot turn the other cheek, I
think is actually like a moral failing
on his part.
>> Got you. Okay. [clears throat and cough]
>> And society would be
>> I suppose past that. How do you feel
about sort of like the implications for
speech online content with this sort of
stuff getting thrown around? Do you you
have any strong opinions about that? You
think it's like, you know, this is
>> my best. So, actually, uh, I I actually
thought about debating Pisco on this,
but uh, we'll see. So, fair use should
be better defined than it's currently
defined right now. I share your anxiety
because I've watched some of your
content on this. I share your anxiety
that if it's narrowly defined, it could
totally [__] up the YouTube ecosystem
and therefore it's not worth the risk.
That being said, uh I think Denims has
the most defensible lawsuit position. I
hope that Hassan and even though I don't
like these people, trust me, I really
really do not like these people. Um I
hope that Denims goes the distance and
sets court precedent and I hope that she
wins. Uh because if she wins where
intent, spoken intent doesn't matter, um
sufficient transformation is what
matters and we get some case law on
that, that could actually be phenomenal.
I
>> I think that's already pretty pretty
much established. I think the bigger
issue honestly is the idea that it could
set the set the standard that if you use
someone's work in full live, that's not
allowed. And that's that's a specific
thing that's that's not like just using
it in full um a full airing of it. And I
think that that would be the bigger
problem because obviously it feels like
you're in sort of like a a catch 22 a
lot of the time where it's not fair use
if you react to the whole thing, but if
you don't react to all of it, they'll
say it's out of context.
>> I think I think the YouTube ecosystem
will probably still do okay in spite of
that just because it feels like a lot of
online creators are more laxidasical
with their uh copyright [__] However, I
do understand uh your exact fear that
effectively like crybullies will use
that as leverage to silence their
critics.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. Well, I mean, we're on the
same page about all that it sounds like
then. So,
>> yeah, free speech is more important.
Okay. Uh I I I'm not a free speech
absolutist. However, um uh freedom
freedom of speech and freedom of
conscience is more important than rich
people's hurt feelings. For sure. For
sure.
Um,
ask him about Mandani and Elsa. Oh,
yeah. Are you on the Elsa is a massive
liar train or are you on the other side
of that?
>> Uh, I haven't seen what Elsa allegedly
lied about. Uh, but I am hostile to the
new wave of progressive uh, democratic
socialists that are coming in.
>> Did you read Dan Sman's free press
article about Elsa?
>> No, I didn't. Although I'm uh I'm happy
for him and proud of him that now he's a
member of the Associated Press. Good for
him.
>> Um what do you think of that? What do
you think about writing for the free
press with all the you know Paramount
acquisition last year and all this sort
of [__] What do you think about writing
for the free press? think that's like
something an upstanding American citizen
does or
>> listen I've done some anti-semitic memes
this conversation but like can you
understand that I'm out here and I'm
getting paid by massage and I'm doing my
honest goyam best to sweep for like the
tepid zionist two-state solution and do
you know how hard it is when like a
Jewish person who is clearly not
qualified takes over like a media wing
of the American mainstream media and
then another random Jewish guy just gets
to publish his own [__] article on
said
>> it's all controlled by one of the
richest Jewish guys in the world who has
a bunch of surveillance companies
>> I'm literally out here I'm sweeping for
the Jews as hard as I can and they keep
making it really hard so if they could
chill the [__] out that would be great
>> okay so so not a fan of the free press
southern Lebanon sorry go ahead
>> yeah sorry so not a fan of the free
press stuff not a fan of people people
aligning with those types to get their
get their work done or
>> I am I am a fan of there being a free
market for expression and Jews amongst
many ethnic religious groups being that
is expressing their political ideas you
know within within that market however
what I think uh you can't do is you
can't buy a media outlet starting
Zionist uh perspective and or hacking
uh people and not expect to attack you
back like what's good for the good for
the gander. So do achieve a um a
plurality a diversity of opinion [__]
discourse that'll be amazing. Um but you
can't throw [__] and expect [__] not to
be thrown back. And I think that's what
people are frustrated with.
>> Sure. Yeah. I I think so. I think also I
just kind of take issue with like, you
know, someone like Dan who wants to
present like he's this, you know,
liberal who hates Trump and all this
stuff, but then he'll go and team up
with people like Barry Weiss who are
like totally willing to, you know, show.
It just feels a bit like, you know, come
on, let's let's stick to
>> Yeah, I had I did have um I've had
conversations with people in the past
where they basic things like, oh, well,
you have to win. You have to play the
game. And I and I basically say to them,
it's not winning at all if you betray
what you're fighting for in doing so.
Um,
>> well, see, that's that's what I think is
so funny about your comments about Dan
because you're like, uh, this is six
months to a year ago or even a few years
ago at this point, but you're like, I
love Dan because he lies, but he's so
open with his naked self-interest.
[laughter]
>> Well, it's just it's easy. It's like,
you know, it's it's easier to address
them when they do that, if you know what
I mean. It's someone's just gonna say,
"I'm alive."
>> Let me let me ask you a question. Do you
think that uh because I actually didn't
I found Dan's argument that he put that
this person is unrelated,
therefore he was not trying to make it
look worse than it was. I saw that as
possible uh but not probable. Are are
you of the opinion because when you read
it out loud, it actually sounded [__]
horrible. Um, are you of the opinion
that all those like redactions or
whatever were intended for maximum
rhetorical effect?
>> I do I do think they massage that for
maximum point outu he's like haha [__]
these [__] not uh necessar I
think they just wanted to redact it all
and they used the term like doc they
didn't say oent service did they say
docs tool right that it's a very the
wording they've chosen for stuff they're
not just using like you know what you
would expect they are trying to make it
sound as bad as possible when they're
when they're sharing it basically
>> yeah I a as an earnest human being I I
have uh I have difficulty spotting
cunning so uh that's funny
>> yeah I I do I do feel feel that I feel
like that that just lines up with all of
Dan's
previous previous actions to be honest,
but hey.
Um, okay. Oh, do be coming again. Feels
like character of stereotypes in the
same way Rabbi Schmoolley is. TBH. Yeah,
I don't think anyone's going to
massively disagree with you on that,
Die.
>> But but Doobie takes it too far in my
opinion. Um he he just like he's like,
"Oh yeah, Argo like therefore because
Zionists exist, they want to claim all
the territory between the Eastern Nile
and the Western Euphrates." And I just
don't think that's going to be
geopolitically possible. So I I I think
I think Doobie is earnest in his
anti-ionist criticism. I do think he
takes it too far.
>> Um yeah, fair enough. Okay. Well, I I I
don't know if I've got much else. I
don't if there's anything else you want
to talk about or
>> Okay. Well, it was it was fun having a
chat where you weren't calling me a
coward and a [__] and I wasn't calling
you a or I wasn't threatening sexual
assault on you. That was a nice
>> That was a nice change of pace.
>> Yep.
>> Um but uh yeah, let's do it again
sometime. So, if there's a
>> topic in contention that you want to
fight about, just shoot me a DM. We'll
do it. And then if there's something
that I feel you're off on, I'll shoot
you a DM.
>> You've got loads of time now as well. So
I expect to see you on JT talk streams
late at night, you know, up until 4 in
the morning. That's that's what I'm
expecting from you Connor now. So
>> listen, I'm not I'm not like totally
opposed to talking to, you know, the
quote unquote snarkers or whatever, but
like you know, you you got you guys
don't make it easy either.
>> What do you mean we don't make it easy?
How do you how do you make it easy? What
do you mean?
did it. So, for example, when you were
talking to Destiny today, I never
thought that I would see you and Destiny
in a room together ever again. So, so it
it it was almost a treat to have Chudlo
Logic Queen and Destiny and Dan Saltman
in the same room again. It felt like the
good old days. But didn't you call him
like a a Felching [__] [__] or some
[__] like that?
>> I I said a lot of things. I said a lot
of things.
>> Right. So, so, so I don't want anybody
who doesn't know what Felchin is to
Google it, but that's very clearly such
an upsetting insult. I mean, Destiny
probably doesn't care, but it's such an
>> I think probably cared about the last
one to be honest, but you know,
>> but but if I ever called somebody a
Felure, I wouldn't expect to speak to
them again, right?
>> Sure. Well, but I mean that's uh you
know, obviously with Destin, I do
genuinely [__] hate Destiny. That
guy, you know, he's done horrendous [__]
to me and people like him.
>> So, so hold on, hold on. This is
actually something that I I do
>> but sorry just to just but for most
people there's like a little bit of
kayfabe you know it's like I it's not
kayfab in the sense I'm only doing it
for the public because I do it in
private too like I I like shouting at
people but it's not like I'm you know
conveying a genuine fully negative
emotion to that person every time you
know I'll tell Becket to you know that
he needs to be strung up and [__] like
this but I don't I don't genuinely I
don't genuinely mean that and me and
Becket you know we we know that
ultimately we're still cool at the end
of the day that's Uh-huh.
>> That's the way it's surprised.
>> Does Becky know that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. We always have this little
afterare session whenever we whenever we
shout each other. Um he's like, "Okay,
fair enough."
>> So, hold on. Let me let me articulate
this. I'll try to be brief.
>> For the sake of content,
I typically want to say yes to almost
anyone who says, "Hey, I got a bone to
pick. Let's talk about it." Yeah. Okay.
But when uh people approach me and you
know obviously uh you know I don't have
a wife anymore to worry about this with
but I do have a girlfriend. If she is
over and she hears you felching [__]
[__] um I'm going to have to explain
that later, you know. [laughter] So we
we got to we got to find the balance.
>> Okay. Got you. Got you. So So it's just
like it's uh you don't like the toxic
image of uh of that of that space. Is
that what you're saying?
>> A little bit for me. Not a big deal for
>> Well, you don't you don't see the toxic
image as beneficial to you and can cause
problems in your personal life. That's
what you That's what you're saying.
>> Thank you for perfectly articulating
what I was scratching at.
>> Okay. Got you. I'm with you.
>> Okay.
>> Well, you have a good night, bud. Catch
you in another six months and we'll
scream at each other then.
>> All right. Catch you later, man. Thanks
for coming on. Bye.
>> Catch you later.
>> Yep. Yep. Bye. Bye.
>> Wow. Wow, guys. What a great talk.